Значення квантових обчислень одночасно недооцінене
і надмірно перебільшене.
Хоча вони не замінять звичайні комп'ютери,
квантові інновації являють собою нову обчислювальну парадигму.
Квантові комп'ютери можуть працювати в унісон з нинішніми обчислювальними
інфраструктурами, вирішуючи складні задачі, які раніше
вважалися нездійсненними або неможливими.
Це може докорінно змінити правила гри.
Наприклад, складність факторизації великих чисел
на прості множники є основою сучасної
криптографії. Для розміру чисел, що використовуються в сучасному
шифруванні з відкритим та закритим ключами, це обчислення зайняло б
у найшвидшого звичайного комп'ютера понад 300 трильйонів років.
Для великомасштабного квантового комп'ютера, що працює
з алгоритмом Шора, це обчислення могло б зайняти секунди.
Такі складні задачі існують у всіх галузях.
Потенційні застосунки квантових обчислень
величезні.
Квантові комп'ютери вже стають більшими
і потужнішими,
поки ми прагнемо вирішувати дедалі складніші задачі.
З 2016 року IBM зробила квантові комп'ютери доступними
для широкого загалу через вебсайт з графічним інтерфейсом,
що нагадує музичну партитуру,
і набір інструментів розробки програмного забезпечення Qiskit,
який дозволяє користувачам програмувати квантові комп'ютери.
Науковці як всередині, так і поза корпоративним світом
проводять експерименти
через схожі портали. Вони досліджують підходи до задач хімії
та машинного навчання, намагаючись з'ясувати,
які питання вони зможуть ставити
і як формулюватимуть їх,
коли технологія просунеться далі. Зараз —
слушний час для бізнес-лідерів підготуватися
до квантових технологій. Умови для експериментів
та розширення цієї принципово нової технології вже склалися.
Організації, що прагнуть бути в авангарді
цього трансформаційного зсуву,
здобудуть конкурентну перевагу. Це навчання
підготує тебе до початку твого квантового шляху!